mind your decisions I'm presto Walker in
triangle ABC a B is equal to AC from
vertices a and B construct line segments
that meet at Point P in the interior of
the triangle suppose P a B is equal to
20 degrees PB a is equal to 10 degrees
and P AC is equal to 60 degrees the
question is to solve for the value of
angle a PC marked as X many people
emailed me this problem it's a very
challenging and fun problem pause the
video if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
before I made the video I posted the
problem to Twitter I was overwhelmed by
the number of responses I want to thank
each person who sent me a solution there
really are many neat and clever ways to
solve this problem in this video I'm
just going to share one solution by
Ahmet Chayton to get started
notice that a B is equal to AC thus we
have an isosceles triangle and the
angles opposite these sides must be
equal to each other since the vertex
angle is equal to 80 degrees each of
these equal angles will be equal to 50
degrees this means ACB is equal to 50
degrees and ABC is equal to 50 degrees
which means PVC is equal to 40 degrees
now let's construct a D such that a D
has the same length as a B and a C and D
AC is a 40 degree angle
this means PA D is a 20 degree angle
Mark E as the intersection of ad with
side BC consider triangle AEC two of its
angles are 40 degrees and 50 degrees so
remaining angle must be equal to 90
degrees this is a right triangle now by
vertical angles d eb will also be equal
to 90 degrees
now let's construct D be consider
triangle abd again this is an isosceles
triangle so the two angles that are
opposite the equal sides must be equal
to each other the vertex angle in this
triangle is 40 degrees so the two equal
angles will have measures of 70 degrees
this means ADB is equal to 70 degrees
and consequently EB D will be equal to
20 degrees we'll now construct DC a DC
is exactly congruent to a BD therefore
we will have a 70 degree angle here
we'll have a 20 degree angle here and we
will have the DC and D B are equal to
each other we will then construct D P
what can we say now
well ABP and ADP are congruent triangles
consequently we must have that this
angle here is 10 degrees which means the
other angle will be 60 degrees we then
consider triangle PB D notice that two
of its angles are equal to 60 degrees
which means the remaining angle will be
equal to 60 degrees therefore we have an
equilateral triangle where all of its
sides are equal to each other from here
we consider a triangle P DC this is an
isosceles triangle with a vertex angle
of 80 degrees so the other two angles
will be equal to 50 degrees each so DP C
is 50 degrees and finally PC e will be
equal to 30 degrees the remaining angle
will be equal to 20 degrees we thus look
at triangle a PC two of its angles are
equal to 60 degrees and 20 degrees
therefore the remaining angle must be
equal to 180 minus 60 minus 20 which
means X is equal to 100 degrees and
that's our answer it's a very
challenging problem but I like how it
all works out thanks for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]